bonsoir et bienvenue dans les débats de
la présidentielle avec ce soir une
question essentielle qui est au coeur de
la campagne
en pleine crise économique comment la
france doit se situer en europe faut-il
aller vers plus de fédéralisme ou bien
au contraire remettre en cause l'euro et
défendre le principe de la souveraineté
nationale bien si bien sûr il s'agit
d'un enjeu considérable et pour en
débattre deux invités jean pierre
chevènement bonsoir ancien ministre vous
êtes candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et vous avez publié il ya
quelques temps la france dans l'impasse
chez l'éditeur
fayard face à wihr la sortir de
l'impasse
sorti à la france de l'impasse voilà
face à vous jacques attali bonsoir aussi
bon choix et vous aussi vous venez de
sortir un livre d'ailleurs candidat
répondait chez le même éditeur fayard
voilà au moins un point commun entre
vous deux et on verra s'il y en a
d'autres dans ce débat pour vous
interroger à mes côtés luc bronner du
monde et gilles leclerc de public sénat
alors principale préoccupation du moment
c'est bien entendu notre monnaie l'euro
et questions très directes jean pierre
chevènement
est-ce qu'il faut sortir de l'euro pour
revenir au franc le risque plutôt que
l'euro dukic nous n'avons pas en
perspective de prendre de décision mais
il n'est pas du tout impossible que à la
suite d'un défaut de l'italie par
exemple ou bien si la france perdait son
triple à
elle sera obligée d'emprunter plus cher
qu'elle ne prêterait à travers le fonds
européen de stabilité financière ou
demain le mécanisme européen de
stabilité donc le système risquerait de
s'enrayer
ça c'est les risques mais vous même
qu'est ce que vous préférez comme
système il est si vous préférez devront
poser dans un livre sortir la france de
l'impasse que nous aimions les allemands
a considéré que la banque centrale
européenne devait intervenir sur les
marchés de la dette
de façon à casser la spéculation de
façon aussi à promouvoir une politique
de change plus favorables pour notre
industrie c'est à dire un euro -
surévalué qu'il ne l'est je vous
rappelle que l'euro a atteint un moment
1 $ 60 il est retombé à 1 30
mais il est encore très au dessus de sa
parité de lancement qui était un 16 si
j'ai bien lu jean pierre chevènement ce
que vous souhaitez ce n'est pas une
monnaie unique comme actuellement mais
une monnaie que vous appelez commune
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est qu'elle
est la différence exact alors dans
l'hypothèse où nous n'arriverions pas à
faire bouger la psycho rigidité
allemande qui refuse absolument que la
banque centrale intervienne et qui au
fond est assez hostile à tout ce qui va
dans le sens d'une mutualisation des
dettes dans cette équation de la forme
d'euro-obligation dont je serais
partisan
si on ne peut pas aller dans ce sens-là
faut bien aller quelque part
et si ils se produisaient les deux
circonstances que je viens d'évoquer à
ce moment là je pense qu'il serait
intelligent de revenir un peu en arrière
pour repartir ensuite de l'avant bien
sûr celle et revenir à une monnaie
commune un panier de monnaies qui
flotterait sur le marché dans la valeur
serait câblées comme l'est aujourd'hui
celle de l'euro qui servirait à me
transactions internationales avec des
éléments de souplesse et de flexibilité
qui seraient les monnaies nationales
parce qu'aujourd'hui ne peut plus
dévaluer
donc on essaye de faire baisser les
salaires les retraites serait plus aiguë
que j'ai
si j'ai bien compris ce ne serait plus
réellement un euro ce ne serait pas le
retour au franc ce serait un euro franc
c'est ça dont il s'agit
ce serait un euro mais qui sera une
monnaie commune qui se déclinerait de
plusieurs manières leur offrant pour
être à valeur de l'euro par exemple ou
légèrement en dessous leurs marques pour
être un peu au dessus on retrouverait le
système monétaire européen bis telle
qu'on l'a connue mais avec comme
finalité d'agréger des pays qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dans l'euro bien
qu'il soit dans l'europe
je pense à la grande-bretagne à la
scandinavie à la suisse ou peco
peut-être à la russie au pays de
l'euroland
on va demander à jacques et a dit ce
qu'il pense de ce panier flottant
d'abord c'est une des questions que j'ai
posées dans mon livre maquis d'être
importés imposé aux candidats donc aux
candidats jean-pierre chevènement je
note que sa réponse
si je peux me permettre cher jean pierre
né le contraire de ce que je pensais
qu'elle allait être puisqu'elle est
favorable comme premier choix au
maintien du système de l'euro unique
comme monnaie unique
à condition de ce qu'un certain nombre
de choses soient organisés et même
favorables aux euro obligations ce qui
est en fait favorable un mot sacrilège
avant la vie dans dans l'esprit de jean
pierre chevènement que je vais tutoyer
parce que dans la vie on se tutoie nous
sommes des amis 2010 allait considérable
c'est que leurs obligations ça conduit
au fédéralisme et moi je suis pour je
dirais d'un seul mot l'euro disparaîtra
comme monnaie unique ou comme les
communes se comblera si dans un échelon
raisonnable nous ne sommes pas dans un
deuxième tir fédéral que je vais
répondre aux questions que vous aviez
dit attention il ya un risque qu'une
chance sur 2 ou un risque sur deux que
l'euro nouvelle bon finalement l'euro à
palinges ol mais vous nous dites
attention le risque existe toujours
c'est pour ça qu'il faut aller si on
vous entend bien dire plus de
fédéralisme a jamais eu
j'ai dit d'abord qu'il pouvait
disparaître si qu'ils ne paraîtraient si
la banque centrale ne se met pas à agir
et contrairement à ce que vient d un
chantier chemin non je pense que la
banque centrale agit massivement et agit
en ce moment massivement et encore ce
matin massivement parce que les hommes
politiques disent qu'ils vont faire des
choses ne font pas la banque centrale
dit qu'elle ne va pas faire des choses
en effet nous sommes aujourd'hui déjà
depuis trois semaines entrez dans une
évolution historique qui est que la
banque centrale a créé un fédéralisme
technocratique de l'europe de l'eurozone
il ya un tel qu'aujourd'hui les italiens
emprunté à -3% et colérique ou l'espagne
a pu lever les héros comme ça la banque
centrale sur la banque centrale a
remplacé les états elle ne peut le faire
que de façon provisoire est aussi
contrairement à ce qu'a dit jean pierre
chevènement
l'allemagne ne peut pas être contre
pourquoi parce que d'une part là parce
que la banque centrale mandy la banque
centrale est indépendante
donc on peut pas dire à la fois que la
banque centrale était indépendant dire
que l'allemagne est contre
si l'allemagne est contre ça n'a aucune
importance puisque la banque centrale
est indépendante donc la banque centrale
indépendante de l'allemagne a décidé
d'intervenir
elle fait du quantitative easing elle
dirait que non si on le lui demandait
mais elle intervient alors là où elle
peut intervenir c'est qu'elle peut
acheter d'un effet des dettes sur le
marché secondaire mais pas sur le marché
primaire viennent elles faible sur le
marché secondaire le fait et elle le
fait indirectement en prêtant de
l'argent aux banques ce matin et hier et
ce matin ont commencé à acheter des
dettes
on va laisser jean pierre chevènement et
pourrait surprendre et puis on vous
redonnera la parole jacques attali quand
vous entends déjà khaled salhi nous dire
la banque centrale européenne qui est
une structure technocratique est en
train d'agir finalement un peu à la
place des politiques qu'est ce que vous
répondez
elle agit en fonction de la mission qui
lui a été donnée par les traités certes
elle a pris quelques libertés
mais trop tard et insuffisamment je
voudrais quand même relevé que l'italie
n'emprunte pas à 3% l'italie a emprunté
hier à 10 ans à 6,62 pour champ ci est
encore très élevé certes c'est un petit
peu moins que c'est urgent auparavant à
7,7 et demi pourcent effectivement il
reste très élevé reste très élevé et
insoutenable pour un pays qui doit lever
250 milliards d'euros dans les mois qui
viennent
quand jacques attali dit plus de
fédéralisme pour sauver l'euro est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez
entendre
vous jean pierre chevènement qui alors
que vous défendez cette idée de
souveraineté nationale
est-ce que c'est compatible heureux je
vais répondre oui et non parce qu'on
confond le problème de la monnaie unique
est le problème du fédéralisme le
problème du fédéralisme est beaucoup
plus vaste pour faire une fédération il
faut avoir un projet qui soude les
différentes composantes l'allemagne
fédérale
c'est l'allemagne c'est le peuple
allemand qui a une unité profonde
les etats unis s'étaient des colonies
britanniques
c'est une nation alors l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne trentaine de
peuples un peu plus même et je prends le
domaine de la politique étrangère ou de
la politique de défense
il n'y a évidemment pas de projet commun
l'allemagne à une politique de cavalier
seul elle met les gaz vers la russie
d'une certaine manière je dis pas
qu'elle a tort mais je les observe
mais est-ce que leur bois à voir ce
projet commun ou pas bien bien
évidemment si vous voulez aller encore
si vous voulez aller vers quelque chose
qui solidarise toujours plus les peuples
européens qui peut être pourrais rendre
possible une construction fédéral dont
je ne veux pas écarter le principal à
long terme
naturellement ça supposerait qu'il y ait
une adhésion des différentes nations car
l'europe n'est pas une entité déjà
constitué ce n'est pas une nation
prenez ce qui ressemblerait le plus à
l'europe c'est la suisse mais la suisse
s'est fait autour des cantons
alémaniques
on y ajouter les cantons romands et le
tessin
mais c'est une très petite partie de la
suisse et je voudrais d'un autre
également répondre jacques attali
on va laisser répondre jacques attali
mais je pense que on ne peut pas parler
de fédéralisme si on parle simplement de
gouvernement économique de la zone euro
avec une banque centrale qui rouge joue
le rôle de moteur aujourd'hui elle ne
joue pas suffisamment
alors je vois bien qu'aujourd'hui elle
prête aux banques un push en temps des
quantités considérables que semble-t-il
ça petit effet mais très minime et on
n'est absolument pas sûr que ça dure en
réalité on n'a pas voulu changer les
statues de la banque centrale européenne
qui nous ont été imposées par carlo
topple par l'allemagne
à l'époque en 1988 89 réponse de jacques
attali
vous verrez pas sur l'histoire parce que
je fais partie des négociateurs et on
vous a rien déposer du tout on a négocié
cela en toute liberté on l'a négocié non
on a négocié tout et mardi seront
absolument pas et le traité tel qu'il
est défini au contraire contrairement à
ce que les gens disent y compris bush
tout achat jean pierre ne conduit pas à
simplement à défendre la valeur de la
monuc puisqu'il est écrit dans le traité
contre les fonds de la croissance donc
l'emploi donc mais revenons pas sur le
passé
ce qui est important c'est de comprendre
maintenant que le fédéralisme découle
tout naturellement de la construction
européenne où on avance vers le
fédéralisme ou l'europe va s'effondrer
on avait un marché commun ce marché
commun ne tenez pas si on ne faisait
part même dans un marché unique qui
harmonise et des normes on a fait un
marché unique ce marché unique ne tenait
pas tant qu'il y avait des dévaluations
compétitives
et quand jean pierre parle du système
des fameux le 6ème du sm ne tenait pas
parce qu'on pouvait faire des
dévaluations compétitives qui remettait
en cause le marché unique maintient que
le marché commun donc on a fait la
monnaie unique qui découle logiquement
du marché commun est là aujourd'hui on
le savait à l'époque
moi je les dis ça a été écrit on en a
débattu à l'époque la monnaie unique ne
tiendra pas s'il n'y a pas à fédéral et
le fédéral ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire avoir non pas à la place de la
souveraineté nationale bien sûr mais en
plus de la souveraineté nationale
un système qui permet d'avoir des
recettes fiscales européennes et qui
permet à l'europe de remplacer les
nations dans la relation peut faire sans
leur coin publique jacques attali ont
plaidé les parlements sont là pour ça et
sont élus et les parlements font ce
qu'ils ont à faire
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que les états ne sont exemple est son
objet d équilibrer leur budget mais
l'europe en tant que tel c'est le point
le plus fondamental notre conversation
l'europe en tant que telle ou l'eurozone
en tant que telle n'a pas de dettes
c'est une entité juridique sans dette
c'est même la seule au monde
entité politique qui n'a pas de dette
des états unis wind est donc si l'europe
ou l'eurozone mon avis qu'est la bonne
espace lever un impôt petit jeu soit
soit la taxe sur les transactions
financières la taxe sur le co2 de pointe
cet hiver elle pourrait avoir des
recettes fiscales s'en servir pour
servir un emprunt genre grand emprunt
français et ferons faire des grands
projets d'infrastructure et là on aurait
une souveraineté partagée parce que
sinon la souverainté
j'ai perdu les soupes perdu à l'égard
des marchés les marchés se taire les
prêteurs puisque les marchés c'est les
prêteurs les prêteurs nous dise mot pour
mot ce qu'ils veulent confère donc le
choix n'est pas entre souveraineté
nationale ou sohu transfère souvent été
à l'europe le choix est en perte de
souveraineté à l'égard des marchés et
jusqu'à 10 jean pierre sueur l'italie
est tout à fait vrai ou consultera
poursuivre notre discussion jacques
attali comme jean pierre chevènement
mais à ce stade du débat
je vous propose d'écouter la réflexion
d'un économiste qui est très anti
mondialisation il s'agit de jacques
sapir qui vient d'écrire sortir de
l'euro justement aux éditions du seuil
et il s'est confié à julien cernobori
fondamentalement dès qu'il ya un
problème sévère le gouvernement national
que la population se retourne
qu'il s'agisse évidemment des ouvriers
d'une usine que l'on va délocaliser
qu'il s'agisse des épargnants inquiet
par rapport à une possible spoliation de
leur épargne fondamentalement tous les
acteurs de la vie économique ne
conçoivent de gouvernement qu'à paris et
ça c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important
cela veut dire que l'union européenne
aujourd'hui n'est pas perçu comme un
adversaire crédible face à la nation on
sait que le gouvernement français depuis
le traité de maastricht a consenti des
abandons de souveraineté qui sont
relativement importants on sait
d'ailleurs dans le même temps que ces
abandons ont été unilatéraux ou en tous
les cas n'ont pas été imité par tous les
pays en particulier dans le cas de
l'allemagne puisque aujourd'hui ce sont
les règles européennes qui doivent se
conformer à la constitution allemande et
non pas la constitution allemande qui
doit se conformer aux règles européennes
mais en même temps il faut bien dire que
les différents c'est de ces différents
abandon de souveraineté pourrait être
révoqué d'un simple trait de plume
alors cette question de souveraineté
elle est bien sûr au coeur du débat
économique on l'a entendu à commencer
par la thématique très reprises dans
cette campagne du fabriqué français et
sur ce point question de luc bronner du
monde
jacques attali on sait qu'il ya eu
pratiquement neuf cents us
fermé en france depuis trois ans près de
100000 emplois industriels perdus comme
en face à ce désastre relancer
l'industrie française comment relancer
le made in france comme dirait françois
bayroux je suis patient il faut le
penser en ces termes simplistes parce
que ça fait 30 ans qu'on dit ça et qu'on
ne fait pas il faut certainement avoir
pensé loin penser loin c'est à dire
penser à des produits nouveaux et pas
seulement fermer les frontières
ça veut dire donc développer la
recherche développer l'innovation ce qui
nous distingue de nos concurrents
allemands et italiens parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on croit l'italie
exporte beaucoup plus la balance des
paiements italienne est excédentaire
donc ce n'est pas l'allemagne face à
l'europe du sud donc c'est d'abord la
recherche innovation des produits
nouveaux j'ai pas sûr qu'il faille pour
cela à fermer les frontières défendez
des structures dépasser la recherche
l'innovation russe point de vue l'action
de l'état pour relancer des secteurs de
pointe sont très importants j'ajoute que
aussi il faut certainement se battre
contre les concurrences déloyales
par exemple si l'industrie
agroalimentaire allemande vient de
passer très largement devant l'industrie
agroalimentaire française c'est bien
chez parce qu'ils ont innovant est
énorme mais c'est aussi parce qu'ils
appliquent la directive bolkenstein qui
leur permet d'importer de la main
d'oeuvre polonaises tchèques et autres
en allemagne à des tarifs de ces pays et
look évidemment les meilleures
situations de coût du travail très par
lever pour défendre que défend jacques
attali parce qu'il vient de nous dire ah
le plus exactement à l'instant fabriquer
français c'est une idée simpliste qu'est
ce que vous répondez
c'est effectivement simpliste où c'est
plus complexe et c'est ce qu'il faut
faire
il y a une très grande hypocrisie de la
part de tous les candidats qui développe
cette thématique
1 je pense par exemple enfin je ne
veulent pas les citer tous parce qu'ils
sont très nombreux mais monsieur sarkozy
ou monsieur bayrou un champ dans le lot
qui ne met pas en cause
en même temps les choix qu'ils ont fait
c'est à dire abandonner la souveraineté
nationale qui est aussi l'expression de
la démocratie comme le souligne à juste
titre jacques sapir qui se trouvait par
exemple économique de madame le pen dans
le genre du maire mais pas moi de
continuer je suis surpris qu'on ait
entendu monsieur sapir conseil madame le
même nom mais je me serais
je voudrais pouvoir prolonger mon
proposition qui est utile on a abandonné
toute protection
aujourd'hui les droits de douane tarif
extérieur commun c'est 070 droits de
douane aux frontières c'est et 14% au
moment où nous sommes entrés dans l'eau
omc en 1994 la libération des moines
capitaux n'est pas tombée du ciel
c'est une application de l'acte unique
un signe en 1985 est adoptée en 87 il
fallait instaurer des droits de douane
aux frontières françaises arrivé je n'ai
pas là vous déviez le problème moi je
pense que la protection est d'abord
monétaire on a toujours sous-estimé
l'importance du facteur monétaire la
monnaie surévaluée de 10 20 30 % c'est
l'équivalent d'un droit de douane de 10
20 30 % et en matière de politique
industrielle 900 jj non fermée depuis
2008 mais nous n'avons aucun moyen de le
défendre
la concurrence c'est la commission
européenne qui interdit la politique
industrielle
j'ai été missionné dustrit je vois ce
quelle autre industrie et l'employé près
de six millions de personnes en 1982
aujourd'hui 3,2 et dans la valeur
ajoutée française par rapport aux bébés
allaités à 28%
elle était adressée française aussi
compétitive que l'industrie allemande et
italienne et l'italienne il faut une
mené moins cher
c'est une condition nécessaire mais
insuffisante il faut que les grands
groupes que nous avons créé
gouvernements de gauche et de droite
confondues apprennent à renvoyer
l'ascenseur parce que ils font leurs
investissements à l'étranger aujourd'hui
pour l'essentiel il faut aider le
surgissement de petites et moyennes
entreprises industrielles il faut une
politique de l'éducation de la recherche
tout ce que nous pouvons dire politique
horizontale mais il faut aussi un
ministère de l'industrie monsieur
madeleine a détruit il faudrait le
reconstituer et il faudrait faire en
sorte que quand on risque de perdre
notre chimie des produits vinyliques
j'étais fière arkema à marseille est
bien le mystère l'industrie s'en
préoccuper 10 mai on fait en sorte que
ce dia pas tous les moyens pris part
un groupe financier américain basé à
genève jean pierre chevènement il ya
tous les moyens que vous venez d'exposer
vous dites aussi une monnaie moins cher
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
concept de monnaie moins cher et dans
ces cas-là à question à tous les deux
monnaies moins cher bon on comprend un
peu de quoi il s'agit mais monnet moins
cher de combien pour qu'on comprenne
bien de quoi il s'est jamais réellement
oui cécile euros étaient moins chers
mais le rôle majeur de combien mais si
l'euro baissait dix ans de leurs 2 15%
on aurait les avantages d'une
dévaluation et sans moyens excessifs de
ce qu'elle représente
il faut savoir aussi qu'il ya des moyens
de comme l'europe fait une grande partie
de son commerce à l'intérieur si la
france de défendre c'est ressources à
l'intérieur son marché sa compétitivité
à la terre d'europe le moyen de le faire
c'est ce qu'on appelle un français était
asocial et ce qu'on appelle en allemand
dévaluation fiscale
c'est une bonne réponse sociale la tva
sociale pour moi est une bonne réponse
que si on la compense parce que c'est un
appeau extrêmement façon transferts de
charges extrêmement injuste mais qui est
excellent en termes de compétitivité et
donc de développement de l'industrie
protection dungey caution la compense
par une réforme de l'impôt sur le revenu
pour compenser la justice ne faut pas la
gâcher
jacques attali c'est la deuxième
solution parce qu'il ya deux choses qui
sont différentes elles euros moins cher
et puis effectivement cette taxe les
importations ou tva sociale de la plaie
des deux manières leurs e mails euros
moins cher comme on arrive un drôle à
leur manière lors d'enchères ne peut n'a
de sens que par rapport aux exportations
hors de la zone à savoir l'intérieur
l'essentiel de l'activité sont à
l'intérieur
moi je regarde surtout le cas italien
mais je réponds à votre question je
réponds d'avoir à votre question on n'a
pas de maîtrise sur l'euro dans sa
valeur par rapport aux autres et aux
autres pays dans la mesure où chacun
fait ce qu'on appelle en dans ce langage
technique un concours de beauté à
l'envers parce que chacun veut avoir
tout amener la plus basse possible les
chinois les américains les européens et
nous ne sommes pas maîtres parce que les
américains sont les maîtres de ce jeu
dont on peut le souhaiter
on n'a aucun moyen y parvenir sauf
peut-être que si la banque centrale agit
trop fortement l'inflation se
déclenchera et on aura à ce moment là
une monnaie très bas ce serait déjà
rempli j'avais à donner mais c'est agir
canal de la banque centrale qui ne se
reconnaît aucune responsabilité en
matière de changes l'euro à un moment
c'était 80 centimes de dollars nous
connaissions une certaine croissance et
l époque 1998 2001 mais avec un euro à 1
30 et à 1,60
évidemment nous sommes une zone de
stagnation
nous sommes la mer des sargasses à
l'échelle mondiale l'europe est le seul
continent où il n'y a aucune perspective
de croissance où les entreprises se
refusent à investir ou les
délocalisations sont massives
on transfère notre appareil de
production vers les pays à très bas coût
vers d'autres pays qui connaissent un
taux de croissance comme les etats-unis
2-2 et demi alors que nous c'est zéro
jean pierre chevènement dans cette
guerre des monnaies comment vous faites
face aux chinois ou américains notamment
qui ont la main aujourd'hui sur sur le
monnaie mais les chinois ils ont décidé
que leurs monnaies que le dollar 1
nous mêmes nous avons abandonné tout le
pouvoir nous sommes en quelque sorte des
fossés c'est pour ça qu'il y à une
colère dans le pays
nous nous sommes des fossés de tout aux
responsabilités sur des instances
absolument technocratique et quand on
parle de fédéralisme il y as mal tonnes
parce que je catelli nous fait miroiter
un fédéralisme des recettes mais rôle et
il sait très bien que le fédéralisme
dont parle madame merkel et monsieur
sarkozy
c'est un fédéralisme budgétaire et un
contrôle des budgets c'est une mise en
tutelle des pays en déficit ce sont des
sanctions automatiques ou quasi
automatique frappant les pays les plus
en difficulté c'est idiot un essai
coercitif et c'est anti démocratique et
c'est la voie ouverte vers une europe
post démocratique
moi je ne veux pas de cette europe là je
suis pour une europe qui sans être
catalogué ni confédéral ni fédéral
jacques delors parler d'opinion objet
politique non identifié comporte dépens
par exemple un gouvernement économique
qui pourrait être appuyé sur une banque
centrale plus interventionniste une
politique de défense mais qui sait dans
un autre cadre plutôt avec la grande
bretagne alors que la politique
économique et monétaire
c'est la journée événement on va laisser
jacques attali vous répondre sur ce
point très précis et puis on passera à
la dernière parole a dissuadé
deux sortes jacques attali d'abord c'est
le raisonnement que jean pierre
chevènement me paraît totalement
erronées sur ce point en tout cas parce
que sur beaucoup de points je suis
d'accord je d'accord sur le fait que la
la probité de concurrence et d'excessifs
d'accord sur le renforcement des serres
de la politique industrielle du rapport
sur le l'importance de droit dan
cohérent l'union européenne mais là nous
sommes parés erronée c'est quand
jean-pierre on dit que l'europe va
imposer des règles contraignantes et que
si on se débarrassait de l'europe
n'aurait pas vrai qu'on traîne en
réalité aujourd'hui
si l'europe ne se donne pas d'un
d'autres pas d'un gouvernement européen
qui soit un vrai ministre des finances
un vrai ministre du budget qui puisse
dire à la banque centrale ne fait très
fier un vrai ministre des finances qui
puisse dire à la banque centrale
je vous demande de faire en sorte que le
taux d'intérêt le taux de change baisse
parce qu'aujourd'hui la banque centrale
s'est auto proclamé responsable du taux
de change alors qu'en fait elle est
simplement responsable de faire
respecter tout change qui devrait être
décidé par les autorités politiques pour
rien si on ne fait pas cela
toutes les ce que jean pierre
chevènement craint venant de contraintes
qui nous serait imposée de l'extérieur
elle nous seront imposés par le marché
par les prêteurs classe voile fourneaux
les terres que ce soit la commission qui
vient déjà de décider demandé à la
belgique 2 mais ce son budget donc donc
le choix est illusoire de dire l'europe
va nous est d'imposer des contraintes si
on s'en sort on ne rend pas de
contraintes non même si on ne scie on ne
va pas vers une souveraineté partagée
entre pays européens
nous perdons nous sommes en train de
perdre notre vote et je dit que quoi
qu'il arrive le prochain président de la
pub et il s'appelle jean pierre
chevènement nicolas sarkozy mme françois
hollande s'il ne fait pas un pas vers la
souveraineté européenne
il n'aura plus aucun pouvoir ce sera
madame lagarde et les marchés qui lui
que jean pierre chevènement on a entendu
et compris votre désaccord sur ce point
là mais c'est maintenant l'heure des
questions d'actualité dans cette
émission
alors la règle de ces questions
d'actualité ce sont des questions brèves
et des réponses bref si possible et
première question de gilles leclair jean
pierre chevènement je m'adresse à vous
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
en matière de politique familiale il ya
une tradition en france qui est le
quotient familial qui a d'ailleurs
favoriser plutôt la famille la natalité
en france il ya eu débat cette semaine
qu est ce que vous vous en pensez
faut-il toucher à cet assaut quotient
familial est ce qu'il est injuste ou
juste je pense qu'on touche le problème
des couches moyennes
on peut plafonner le quotient familial
pour les deux des cils supérieurs
et puis crée des allocations
supplémentaires pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui ne bénéficie pas du quotient
familial
mais attention aux effets pervers il y
en a beaucoup je crois que l'on peut
comme l'a dit françois hollande
d'ailleurs amende et ben me greffe ou
s'il allait amender le quotient familial
mais ne bousculons pas une politique
familiale qui marche sur ce point
jacques attali sur ce point d'abord il
faut le replacer dans le contexte
général il va nous falloir trouver 90
milliards de recettes ou d'économies
dans dans trois ans pour que le défi de
la dette ne dérape pas donc on peut dire
non à tout mais à un certain moment on
fera quand même le faire sur ce point je
constate
premièrement que tous nos grands
démographe nous disent que le dise
allocations familiales le quotient
familial
le quotient familial en tant que telle
n'a pas d'impact démographique
deuxièmement qu'il est aujourd'hui
extraordinaire monténégrin terre comme
l'a dit jean pierre faynot parce qu'il
va les plus pauvres ont zéro les plus
riches ont 4000 euros par mois ce qui
est quand même souvent gigantesques
grâce au quotient familial et que pour
moi
l'intégration progressive partiel dans
l'esprit de ce que vient de dire jean
pierre vieu quotient de caution des
allocations familiales dans le revenu
imposable ne paraît ça vous rapporterait
deux milliards et demi sur 90 qui sont à
trouver donc oui comme on entretient sa
sécurité de 2 séparent résultat ça n'a
aucun rapport avec l'objet
vous n'avez pas démontrée je vous cite
les travaux d armer le bras de poudre en
donnez nous plus grands économies et
dépendra transférabilité à ses
références et autres questions de luc
bronner jean pierre chevènement marine
le pen atteint 20% d'intentions de vote
dans les sondages aujourd'hui s'il ya un
risque de présence de marine le pen au
second tour est ce que vous retirez
votre candidature je pense que ce risque
aujourd'hui n'existe pas mais bien
évidemment les sandales bien évidemment
il y à une colère dans le pays et je
pense qu'il y a maldonne sur l'idée de
la souveraineté nationale
on n'a pas développé la souveraineté
nationale comme ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire le point d'appui pour
exercer des effets de levier vers
l'extérieur vers l'europe vers le monde
ah on a considéré que souveraineté
nationale c'était synonyme de repli donc
on a fait un peu le lit du front
national
noélie de droite et de gauche ont fait
le lit du front national
et je pense qu'on peut combattre le
front national avec une politique
énergique qui fait fond sur la
souveraineté nationale
non pas pour que la france se replie sur
elle même mais pour que au contraire
elle fasse bouger l'europe et que
notamment dans leurs rapports avec
l'allemagne nous amenions l'allemagne a
changé à ne pas faire une politique de
cavalier seul mais à penser ce que le
genre gaulle appelait une europe
européenne
jean pierre chevènement est ce que dans
votre tête il ya quand même quelque part
la possibilité que vous puissiez un
moment ou un autre vous retirer et
peut-être il y aurait un élément
déclencheur à ce moment là mais vous
savez j'ai dit que j'étais candidat pour
faire bouger les lignes 1
donc j'ai clairement inscrit ma
candidature dans une démarche
pédagogique
je regarde comment évoluent les
différents quand il ya eu ce volume 1 et
françois hollande par exemple a admis
que la banque centrale européenne devait
intervenir plus puissamment là où je
suis un peu inquiet c'est comme je
l'entends dire que à un mauvais accord
vaut mieux que pas d'accord du tout moi
je pense qu'à certains moments pas
d'accord du tout vaut mieux qu'un
mauvais accord
gilles leclerc jacques rethel il ya un
rapport dont on a beaucoup parlé cette
semaine sur le temps de travail en
france des français les français qui
apparemment travail six semaines de
moins par exemple que les allemands est
ce que c'est une vraie question en
termes de compétitivité et de
mondialisation
oui d'ailleurs ça fait partie du jeu
cinquante trois questions sur lequel je
souhaite que les candidats se prononcer
il y en a beaucoup qu'on a évoqué
aujourd'hui mais beaucoup d'autres qu'on
n'a pas évoqué mais qui sont tout à fait
central c'est vrai que la durée du
travail est très importante
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les français
travaillent moins que les autres mais je
pense que l'essentiel doit se juger en
termes de quantité qualité de travail
puisqu'on dit quantité de productivité
globale qui se joue en fonction de la
recherche d'innovation et surtout de la
formation aujourd'hui les grands
problèmes de la société française c'est
que les chômeurs ne sont pas formés et
que des quelque 1 bascule au chômage et
bien ça que sa qualification et ne
trouvent plus et ça fait de façon
cumulative baisser la quantité dans
votre lit rusal qu'attali vous expliquez
bien que pour faire des économies pour
avoir à d'autres systèmes qui se met en
place par exemple vous dites il faut des
réductions drastiques
il faut supprimer beaucoup de niches
fiscales et vous ajoutez je serais pour
la suppression d'un cinquième semaine de
congés payés non non c'est pas ça avait
mal lu je ne se livre dans ce livre ce
n'est pas un livre de qui définit un
programme qu'est ce que vous en pensez
jeudi attendait jeudi à 153 sujet réglé
et sur lequel je pousse les candidats
une réponse
et jeudi il ya une des questions qui est
des économies ou des recettes nouvelles
il faut en trouver 90 milliards et je
donne simplement deux choix à chaque
question sur les 153 de choix qui me
paraissent possible un choix qu'on peut
qualifier de gauche un choix qu'on peut
les qualifier de droite et il faut que
les candidats seront dans ce qui est
pour l'instant je n'ai pas entendu les
candidats dire où ils ont trouvé les 90
milliards et jeudi qu'une des solutions
qui n'a pas ma préférence mais dans ce
livre je donne pas mes préférences
je dis simplement ce qu'il faut si bien
la suppression des 5e semaine de congés
payés ou via des augmentations d'impôts
par la suppression des niches fiscales
je montre simplement qu'il ya
différentes pistes possibles
j'attends que les candidats se
prononcent pas ce que les électeurs ont
besoin de savon et parmi ces épices vous
vous citer la possibilité de supprimer
des chaînes de congé mais ce n'est pas
mon choix je dis simplement ce qui est
possible
luc brodeur jean pierre chevènement la
police française et traversé par une
série de scandales une affaire à lyon
une affaire à lille et une affaire qui
implique l'inspection générale des
services que faire aujourd'hui pour
moraliser la police française s'il
s'avère que l'inspection générale des
services
à fabriquer des preuves c'est
extrêmement grave je n'hésite pas à le
dire je pense que une question se pose
qui est celle de l'éthique républicaine
et elle se pose à tous les niveaux mais
elle se pose particulièrement dans les
polices particulier au ministère de
l'intérieur il faut y être très attentif
parce que c'est la confiance que les
citoyens peuvent avoir en l'état qui
souffre
je suis très surpris de ce qui s'est
passé à lille ou à lyon
je pense que il y a incontestablement un
relâchement du contrôle déontologique
normalement la spéciaux en général des
services devrait veiller sur des
comportements déviants quand il
n'existait ils sont souvent sévèrement
sanctionné la police il ya beaucoup de
champions dans la police je dirais que
le souci de la déontologie
toujours inspiré les ministres
d'intérieur de gauche et j'ai le
sentiment que ce n'est plus vraiment le
cas aujourd'hui
jean pierre chevènement le vote des
étrangers aux municipales vous y est ou
non favorable je crois que vous y êtes
favorable mais que vous n'avez pas voté
au sénat
non j'y étais favorable par une espèce
de sap et du naturel
et puis je me disais pourquoi au port
pour les étrangers non communautaires
puisqu'on fait pour les étrangers
communautaires
sauf qui a pas de réciprocité et puis le
problème n'est pas là le problème c'est
l'intégration et je privilégie mois la
voie de la naturalisation qui évidemment
aujourd'hui et n'est pas privilégiée par
l'actuel gouvernement
puisque nous avons 30% de naturel
naturalisation en moins d'une année sur
l'autre mais je pense que c'est plus
simple et plus respectueux du concept de
citoyenneté qui est une une conception
globale on est citoyen d'un pays quand
qu'on se prononce sur le local mais
aussi sur le national tout ça va de pair
dont bien aujourd'hui vous y êtes ou pas
favorable à cette proposition non je n'y
suis pas favorable à ce que je suis je
suis en retrait je n'ai pas pris part au
vote pour manifester que à mon sens on
n'a pas suffisamment réfléchi à cette
question notamment risquent de
communautarisme dans les villes de
banlieue je pense qu' il peut y avoir
des pressions et je le constate même
dans la ville d'angers était maire il
peut y avoir des pressions 1 qui
s'exerce de tel ou tel groupe qui va
obéir au doigt
l'autorité puis moins inconnu mais pour
fausser le jeu des élections la
citoyenneté c'est d'abord la sphère du
citoyen qui est à dire un individu qui
est doté de raison qui a le sens du
collectif questions sur la même
thématique jacques attali et puis autre
question si je puis me permettre
dans votre livre vous traiter de tous
les sujets y compris d'ailleurs de
sujets de société où on sait que nicolas
sarkozy imagine de peut-être mettre dans
ce programme
un mariage qui pourrait être ouvert aux
homosexuels quelle est votre position là
dessus vous jacques attali est même
question à jean pierre chevènement dont
je suis favorable évidemment l
uniformisation des règles de nos
relations et le mariage homosexuel en
particulier me paraît tout à fait
naturel pour créer les mêmes conditions
de droits de transmission de patrimoine
ça me paraît une nécessité évidente je
pense que de ce point de vue la classe
politique française toute entière est
maintenant à peu près rallier à ce point
de vue jean pierre chevènement écoutez
je ne suis pas du tout certain que ce
que vous dites waouh vrai j'ai été
l'auteur d'une proposition de loi qui
s'appelait contrat d'union civile qui a
donné le pacs notre nom qui résout le
premier patrimoine que vous venez
d'évoquer il ya un autre point de vue
qui est celui des enfants sains et je
pense que l'adoption est permis un
célibataire
donc le problème il est réglé je ne vois
pas vraiment la nécessité de cette
réforme sinon elle est toujours dans le
sens du vent est substitué finalement
une approche purement sociétale à une
approche sociale ce que les socialistes
ont malheureusement oublié de faire et
bien voilà ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à tous les deux et dans une
semaine rendez-vous pour à nouveau débat
de la présidentielle